it's the day before
the big cook and i've got one last
very important stop on the border of the
great smoky mountains
is the national park that is inhabited
by the cherokee indians i've heard
that there is a cherokee dish that i
need to taste to believe
we are right in the thick of the woods
[Music]
malia there you are shioko
what does that mean it means hello
gordon and how are you oh
i'm so happy to be here now homily
harmony harmony hominy
is a very unique traditional native
american food
it's basically corn on steroids and i'm
finally about to see
how it's made the process of turning the
corn to harmony
just relies on this ash this hickory ash
and the corn and water
and heat are ready yeah first off if you
can finish getting the rest of these
kernels
off and once you get a few of them see
you're looking like a pro go sure and
then we're gonna come over with our ash
and go over to the fire that actually
turn it black watch it
it's the lye that's in the ash that we
need to remove the coat off of the
kernels
it makes it easier to digest now
i know why there's such a buzz around
this dish there is lie
in hickory ash which is extremely
corrosive
i'm excited to be showing what this
unique ingredient will do to humble corn
kernels
and it also makes some more amino acids
available to you
and you have less vitamin deficiencies
it makes sense
that the cherokee developed a recipe
that would maximize nutrients
but i'm not sold on this dish just yet
so does the ash turn it bitter it
doesn't turn it bitter but it does give
it a different taste
yeah see it doesn't look appetizing well
i'm sure sometimes when you make a dish
it doesn't look that appetizing until
you're all the way done right
malia has obviously never seen me cook
while we wait for this caustic mixture
to work its magic
i learn about the traditional way of
grinding corn
straight in yeah yeah all right does
that go in there
you just which is that right round
pound what do you think well it looks
like the the sort of
that end's too big for the hole but then
that doesn't
no let's try this how many kids do you
have one
malaya please girl honestly so all right
i'll i'll give you a little help i'll
give you a little help
it won't go down the hole turn it around
oh you do turn it on turn it around
so secrets not to go too hard right
right
yeah i'll have to teach you how to say
help me and cherokee
yes please she stay la stella
ski stella ski it means help
and right now i need a ton of it so
you are using a lot am i
look how slow you're going work smarter
not harder yes
yes ma'am indigenous science gotcha slow
and steady here we go
doesn't feel right
[Laughter]
i'm sure you'd like to keep watching me
awkwardly poke around
but thankfully it's time to try our
hominy which has been thoroughly rinsed
and mixed with beans
that looks i mean it's almost like a
sort of french casserole
you know like a bean stew yeah
um see how lovely
been waiting for that all day that is
delicious oh my god
the corn and the beans on a different
level she elevated that dish into
something quite luxurious
that cherokee history is so prevalent
today and i need to tap into that if i
don't tap into that
i'm i'm dead me thank you thank you
[Music]
want to see more from my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips